DANA PERINO WI "THFIV."
♪ ♪
THBIDEN WHITE HOE DEPENDING
ITS CISION TO SWAPHE
MERCHA OF DEATH FOR BA
BASKETBALL STA BRAND-NEWIDEO
SHS BRITTNEY GRIR ONER WAY
BACK TO THE U. AFTER TENMONTHS .
SHE S SET TO DO NI YEA OF
HARD TIME FOR HAVING CANBI
OIL AND R LUAGE.
CONVICTED A RUIAN ARMSEALE
VIOR WAS ALL SMILES ER T
TRE APPEARED THIS GUY IS A
SEOUSLY BAD DUDEONSPING TOKILLMD
TOERRORISTS.MEWHILBIDEN LEFT HOD
HE W DOING A 16 YE SENNCE.
FOCUS BUYING CHARGES RE APETERA
GOA RAW DEAL.
>> IN THE ISON SWAP, WHY D
BRITTNEY GRIR GET A TTER
DE?
OUR CHOICE WAS BRITTNEYR NO
ONE AT A.
BRING HOMENE AMERICAN OR NOAMER.
>> A PROFIC ARMS DEAR WH
WAS CONVTED OF TRYING  KILL
AMERANS WHO ISALLED THE
MERCHANT ODEATH.
EAK WITH A PROSSIONAL
ATETE IS ALSAN ARICAN
CIZEN.
LET'S NOT FORG THAT.
WHO SERVED -
Gre PAUL WHAN WDERING
WHY NOT MO WAS DONE TO GET
THEMACK ME.
>> YOU TELL MEHABRITEY IS
GOING ME TODAY.
AND THAT TRER WE HOME AND HE
DI BUT I DON'T UNDERSTD WHY
I'M STILSITTG HERE.
BAGS ARE PACK.
M REY TO GO HO.
I JUST ND AN APLANTOOME
AND T ME.>> Greg: REPUBCANSARRAT
THIS TRADE PUTS A BOUNTY ON
EVERY SINGLE ARICAN.
>> THINKBOUT THE EHANGE
HERE.THE MERCHANTF DEFOR A WNBAN
WHAT A VICTO FOR PIN BWHATDOES Y
ERICAN WHO IS ERSE
VUERABLE, WHY?
THEY CAN PICYOU UP ON A
TRUMPED UP CRGE TO GET
MEBODY THEY NT O.>> Greg:LL RHTL
I THINK YOU KN, BY THE WAY
GO TO E YOU.>> Harol GOOTOE BA.
Greg: S, AND BLE TV BUT
DON'EXPECT YOU TO HAVE MORE
TH ONE IDEIN YOUR HE AT
THSAMEIME.
YOCAN SATHAT YOU A HAPPY
SHE'S BA, BUTHIS IS A LOUSDEAL.
YOU CAHAVE TWO COMPENG
THOUTS IN YOUR HEA
ULD YOU AGREE TH THAT?
QUESTION MKS BE TOSURE.
FIT OF ALL I GLAD E'S ME
AND I PRAYOR PAUWHELAN, THE
SECOND TIME TROR RD WAS
RELEED A NOT RELEASED.
ERE WAS SOMEING TH STORY
THAT DON FULLY UNDERSTD.I AGREES
BUT THEY WE SOTHING HERE
THEY HAVE GOEN ERCISE ABOUT
E RUSSIANS.
I'HAPPY SHE'S ME B IOULD
ASK OSE WHO N'T DO WT YOU
ARE DOING,HICHS TO HAVE TWO
IDEAS IN YR HEAD AT ONCEHO
EM TBE SO EXERCISED TH
SHE'S HO AND FIXATED O
HER BEING PROFSIONAL
ATHLETE.THE QUESTION IOULDAVE IS
REAL TWO CE I ULD TAKE THE
ADMINIRATI AT THEIR WORD
THIS IS THE ON DEAL THEYOULD
GET.
FOR OSWHO BELIEVE TH
BECAE SHISOME SOMEHOIT
IS A FRONT TO MRWHELAN.
SHOU WE HAVE LEFT R THERI WOD AT
LEAVHER THERE.
IT SEE IF U BELIEVE WHATHE
ADMISTRAON IS SAYING, IS
IS ODEALHAT THEY WERE
OFFED.NOW, AGA I HOPE THAT THE
WHAN FAMILY AND MY PYERS,
THEY TWEETEDTHERE IS NO
GREATER SUCCESS R E WORLD TO
RETA TO BE FREE TO GO HOME AND
THE DEN MINIRATION D THE
RIGHDECION TO BRING
MS. GRINER CE HO RATR THANWAITIT
GOING TO.
I HOPE THEIDENDMINISTRATION
DOESOT GE UP ON THFRONT.
I INK MR. McCAHY CE OF
THLID OFHE ABOUT AMECANS
VOLALE AROUND THE RLD.
BUT I HOPEE ISOTLAMI THE
ADMINIRATI FORHAT.
I WAPLEASED TO SEE ALSAS I
FINISHERE,RITTNEY GRINER
FE, AT THE WHI HOU, SH
ANKEALL THPEOP THAT
HELP AND EVEN MEWH
MILEVEL PEOPLE ITHE
STATDEPAMENT AND ORSEA
AND EVENOVERTHE KE
VERNORATE RICHDSONE
PROVIDED.
SO, WHATEV THEY REOTBLE
DO TO G PAUWHEL HOME, IHOPE THE
DESERV TO  HOME ASELL.
>> Greg: JUDGEHARO, I KIND
OF SENSE FROM AT HOLD SAID,
THE UNITED STES  HAD OVERTHE BAE
RDS.
THEY PUT HER AY FONINE YEARS
MA IT  AMAZING BARGAINING
CHIP.WAS THERE ANY Y TH COULD B?
>> Jnine: LOOPWHENOURE
DEALING WITHHESEINDS OF
NEGOTIIONSND YOU HAVE PEOPLE
UNDETHE TABLE ATHE TLE
COME AROUND E TABLE ON BOTH
SIDE THERE IA LOT OF LERS
WHATS GOG ON.
FAR BE IT FOR ME TO KNOW.LET ME
AD S IS HOME.
BUT THINK U HAVE GOTBAMA
EN HWAS ESIDENT D BIDEN
AS VICE PRESIDT, T DEMS HA
A STOROF B TRAS.WE GIVE  THE WON
EXCHANGE FOA DESEER.
D THEXCHANGE BUT HAVING SA
AT MHEARD THE PRESENT THIS
MORNING ANI THOUT ANYO
ARE ING TO BE SHOCD, I
OUGHHE DID AREAT JOB AT
THPRESCONFERENCE THI
MOING.
I THOUGHT E WHELANAMILY WERE
INCRIBLYRACIOUS TODAY.
BUT HERE ITHE THING.
THEY ARE SAYG ITAS BRITTANY
OR NO E.
T WHCHOSE TO MAKE E TRE?
THE SSIAN OSE TO ME THE
TRE.
IT WASHE RSIANS WHDECIDED
AT THIS WAS THE MOMENT.
THEY WTED THE MERCNT O
ATH OUT, THERMS DEALERUT
HERE TY ARIN THE MIDDLE OF A
WA
WH DOETHAT TELL YOU?
EYANTED TO MAKA DEAL.
D I DON'T KNOW IF WE COULD
HA SAID MORE OR ULD VE
MAND MORE, BUT THES A
PART OF ME THASAYS, "YOU WAN
THE DEAL B ENOUGH TO G TT
DIRTG, THEN YOMAKE THE
DEAL.">> Greg: DIDT EVEN MAKTHET
AND HAVING TO DO WH THWAR IN
UKRAINE.I DI'T EVEN INK OFHAT.
THAT IS CHILNG.
NA, I WANT TO SETHIS.
CAWE THROW UP THIS WDY RDI
WEGART TWEET?
COME ON.
THERE YOU GO.
A EAT RELIEF, EXAORDINAR
NEWS A POSBLE ORE BUT ALSO A
BLACK MAN IS RELEASE
AND OFOURS THETHER
PRISERS.
IT WAS LIKE SU A
AFRTHOUGHT.>> Dana:HE WORSTWEETF
22.
>> Greg: I WONDER WHELAN
SHOULD STARTDENTIFYING AA
BLACK.
>> Dana: I'M SURE HE WDERS
GHT?
UESTION WERE CING FROM
I OUGHT THE PRESS R KATERI'SRESY
BRITEY GNER IS ALSAN
AMICAN
I THOUGHTHAT WAS AECENT
ANSWER THEREBUT I THINK SO
WHATOU WERE ASKING, HAROLD
ITIAY EVEN BRITTANY'WIFE
D THOSE TWO GOHOUGHTS INER
HEADS D SHARE THAT WITHEVERYBOD
SHHAS A RANGE OF EMOONS.SHE PROD
BRTNEY ARE GOINGO COINUE
USE THEIR POW, THR VOICE
ANTHEIR LEBRITY AND TH
BAING  THE MEDIA IN ORDER TO
HELP G PAUWHELAN O AND
HER STAGES AROUND E WOD.
YOUAN THINK OF IS AS ATACTICALC
LOSS.
BEUSE PUTIN HAS NTEDIM
NY, MANY YEARS.
WHAT HE IS DOI IS KING
HIGH ANDIGHER PROFIL
TARGETUNTIRATCHET UP T
PAIN ENOUGTHATE WOULD SAY,ALLBA.
BUT WH KEV McCARTHY WAS
SAYINGS A NERAL COERN TH
THE STATE DERTME HAS LONG
HE WCH IS, IF YOU LL THESEREGIMT
OUPEOPLE, REMEMB
TO WMBIER, HE DIED.
D HE WAS A STUDENT.
BUT THEY KW AT AMERICANS
WILLO WHAT WE HAVE TO DO TO
MAKEEALLY HARD DECISIONS AND
TOH CHOICES FOR TH.
TREVOR REIALSO WHEN  WAS
LEASED, HE WASERY UPSET TH
PAUL WHELAN HAD NOT BEEN
RELEASEDT THE SAMEIME.
SO, M JU WONDERING AT IS
POINTHEN, WHATOUR
LERAGE?
IFHAT PUTIN WAED THE MOST
WAS VIKTOROUT,HAT IS THE
NEXT ASKO GET WHELAN A WHAT
WE HAVE ON THE TABLE TO
FER?
I'M NOT SURE.
>>reg: JESSE, WH ARE YOUR
THOUTS QSTION MIKE>> Jesse: IT E
THWORS
BUTHISOMAN, I'M GLAD SHE'S
BA AND SHE'S ANTI-AMICAN ANDPRO.
>> Greg: RIGHTMAY BE.>>esseWHEL.
I HA A HARD TIMEELIEVINGE
DI'T HE MORE LEVERAG
IF WE HA ALL THE SENTIEN ON
THE SSIANS AND ALL THENERGY
ON THE GROUND OF THEUNITED STAT?
I N'T KNOW, WE H TO LET THE
BIDEN NEEDS THE PARIAH F OIL
AND HOAGES?
JOWENTVER AND FIST PUMP AND
STOP PRODUCTN, SWED IT DOWN
AND EN BEGGING HIMO CUA
DEAL AND IT GE THE MERCHANT
OUT.
I MEAN, I DON'T KN WHAT LITTLE
CKETAN CAN DO ANY WORSE
E UNITED STAS.
THIS W BAD ON ALL ACCOUN.
W, THE MCHANT AFTER THE
UNION COLLAPSE HE OK ALL OF
THE STUFF,ILES OF WEONS D
LOED TM UP ITHE CAO
AIRCRA INTESDUMP TENOF
EVERY TERRORT OUP RTEL,RY JUNGL,
AFCAWAR CRINAL, MORE
AK-47S THAEVER NEED.
THIS GUY H AMECAN BLOOD ON
HIS HANDS ANWILL PROBABLY LEAD
TO MORE AMICAN DEATHPUTIN TAETE.
HE KNEBY CHOING A BLACK,
CELEBRITY, IWOULD PUT E
LITICAL SQUEEZON BEN.
EVERDICTATOR KNOWSHO TO
TAETAY WOKE RSON IN THE
WHITE USE.
NOW, HAVE TO SAY SOMHING.
IFOU A BRITTY'S AGENT AND
YOU ARE NDINBRITTNEY GNER
TO RUSA A WEEK BORE PUTIN
INVADES UKINE,HAT IS ON U.
IS WAN, LISESENT HER
CLIENT WITH DRUGS  RUSA
ILE ERE WAS BATTALIO
ENCIRCLING UAINE AND SAID,
OPS.
YOU N'T AME PUTIN BECAUSE HE
ANIMAL.
ANIMALS DOHAT ANIMALDOTHEY
WILLAKE A HOAGE.
THIS WAN WHEN BRITTN COMESDOWN,.
OIL D FIRE THIS AGT.
Greg: TT ISUNNYHAT
ISHE ANTHAT YOU ARREALLY
MAD AT.>> Dana: IIS TE, AGREE.>T
MORTO BLAME THAN PUTIN?
>> Jse: EN YOU PLAY WITH
THE TIGER,HE TIG WILL SMH
R FACE END.
>> Dana: WLE YOU WERE
TRAVELING ERE ATHAT TIME,THERE S
ERYWHERE FOR ARICANS NOT
GO
>> Jeane: THERE WERE OTH
AMERICANS ONHE TEAM HERE
>> Harold: THERE WE OTHER
AMERL
TEAM.
Dana: A KEY F THEM THEY
WE NOT CHOSEN AND PUN CHOSEHER.
>> JesseIS AT THE STAR OR
THE DRS?
>>reg: I THINK S
UNRSTANDS THE SAIFICE IS
COUNY GA HER HER BECAUSE WE
DON'T KNOW WT TH GUY I
PABLOF N THAT HE IS EE.
>> Da: 5YEAROLD.
>> GreMAZING.
>> Harold: ARICA'S ABILITY
TO FOL